[Musique]
master dans la saison 2 il est dans une
période de transition et il sort son
premier film s'appelle liberable un film
d'action ou juin que tu vois un truc un
truc juste une petite seconde je voulais
te féliciter
et
puis au dernier moment
[Musique]
des images de mon téléphone portable
dans un Multiplexe de la région lilloise
va nous permettre de d'incarner la
descente
ça aussi c'est facile à raconter on
prend ma star en saison 1 que j'ai
imaginé comme un rappeur très en place
un rappeur a du lait
rappeur avec plusieurs disques d'or une
grande carrière
il fallait qu'on raconte aussi ce qui se
passe quand ça retombe donc le
personnage de ma star nous permet de
raconter quel rat il y a des hauts y a
des bas quand c'était très douloureux
très compliqué surtout quand on a fait
les mauvais choix de ma star à moi des
fois
tu vas aller voir pour faire court en
face tampon entre lui et carnage et il
se dit bon il est obligé d'accepter de
faire un album en commun avec lui sauf
que ma star est dans une phase
descendante et du coup à l'école il est
un peu mal en point donc il en studio et
puis ça se passe pas très bien et tu
peux le faire
je crois c'est mieux qu'on arrête là
pour aujourd'hui
pourquoi tu casses les couilles qui
vient avec moi qui parle mal à robe là
c'est bien là ce que vous proposez
pour la seule chose qui va démarrer
c'est ta charrette
pourquoi toi tu veux faire maintenant
tout de suite on est c'est fini
débrouille-toi avec avec ton arrête la
collaboration et cetera
terminé
et c'est le moment où tu sens que ma
star se rend compte qu'en fait il est en
train de tout perdre puis rien ne marche
là il y a plus d'échappatoire
pour cette bonne encore plus bas
tu as voulu faire affaire avec lui sans
passer par mois
lui c'est la rue c'est pas grave
maintenant tu es tout seul
tu as des vrais comme avant
carrelage qui est incarnée par le
rappeur Bosch maintenant on peut dire le
rapport au moment où on a commencé les
gens ne savais pas qui c'était
maintenant ils savent tout ce
qui est carrelage mets un événement
incroyable les gens ont découvert ce
personnage de carrelage mais j'ai
tellement de gens même métiers du cinéma
qui m'ont appelé où est-ce qu'il est
incroyable il me fait peur
en saison 2 car la j'arrive plus énervé
que jamais il a des comptes à régler et
il est pas du genre très diplomate
carrelage
du début à la fin
qu'est-ce qu'il va dire parce que il y a
pas que
qui font ce moment
qu'est-ce qui va lui balancer comme on
est
[Musique]
William il pensait que c'était y a marre
de ce qui avait tué son ami ça veut dire
à partir du il se rend compte que c'est
carnage d'étages
je pars là pourquoi je le cherche
parce que la découverte éducateur page
il y a quelque chose que j'ai appris
avec la série qui est fantastique et les
gens c'est tu vois c'est un truc en
plastique ça et
ben je voulais quand même laissé des
pistes de réflexion pour les gens
ça veut dire que
j'ai pas cherché à cacher j'ai pris le
vrai comédien qui a un casque c'est sa
vraie moto il a toute la série qu'il a
même sur la deuxième saison il arrive
avec son T-Max et c'est lui qui descend
le problème quand tu écris un personnage
comme celui de carrelage qui est
extrêmement violent
il y a un moment il va lui arriver des
problèmes c'est sûr
parce que tu lui fais faire des choses
qui vont tellement loin
que
tu as tout fait au bout d'un moment
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire de plus après
tu vois ce que je veux dire il est il
est tellement dur tellement violent
et
puis voilà
et alors attention à toi Marie
donc je la vois pas la marque beaucoup
de ce genre de scène justement quelqu'un
avec tout ce que ça implique
de
d'orgueil en fait
cette semaine là j'ai eu du mal à
tourner un peu ça m'a un peu énervé de
me faire fumer au moins 10 fois
d'affilée comme ça il s'appelait aussi
signé la fin de carnage moi c'est quoi
un gilet
il y en a un mais tu es sûr qu'il était
mort et finalement ils sont pas morts et
puis on a on était sûr qu'il est pas
mort depuis son mort
[Musique]